we unleashed something powerful we have
to stop her if you want to do something
right you make a list happy team - we
got to fight ghost three we're gonna
track down ghost
that seems like she'd be part of two -
eh
watch this
Oh also we have to save the world that's
major we can't forget that
so how long have you been Antonin again
no uh I just sort of happened
it's like bad guys like you
[Music]
I seem to mess it up almost every time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watchful
back
blank apartment
[Music]
dr. pan I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when his crazy could be go still
like walks through walls and stuff
slowly otech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever
who would have believed that in your
hour of need you would turn the house at
me because we robbed you do you remember
that's us
feeling chance we've got this oath the
deal
and man in the wasp teaming up follow my
lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
[Music]
we're gonna die
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny
I was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you've 65 feet 65 if you
to our finish comparing sizes 65
[Music]
you